this is my main field
of activity I would say today
as anyway at the time of my thesis and
then what I was hired for
is the study of discharges in
insulating liquids then insulating liquids
are mainly used in
very high voltage transformers or
other voltage is obviously these
transformers they have problems in general
and these problems are generally due
to the problems of breakdown of the liquids
in these transformers
so it is important to understand in
fact the discharges to be able to do
understand the faults of its
electrical equipment and more
generally the faults in a lot
of electrical equipment then a
mathematics aims is already there in the
laboratory when I was in the
laboratory it was already used by
some researchers in the laboratory
it  a long time ago fifteen years ago
at least that's when I would say we
started using it a lot  read more and
then today it's a bit the
almost main tool so we have
experimental results its experimental results
we will be able to analyze them
with mathematics quite easily and
possibly compare them to
model theories so the
first two  will actually concern I
would say the aspect of charges in
insulating liquids therefore in a liquid
so there how to say there the books
while I begin to explain so
therefore we are going to try in fact to understand
the application of the electric fields of the
strong electric fields  on
insulating liquids mathematica is very
interesting for the analytical calculation aspect
but also sometimes calls
on numerical calculation and
there I would say that the great interest of
mathematics is enough to be able to
combine analytical
calculation with numerical calculation in a  one and the same
formulation of codes and to be able
to mix it all up to
come out with a confro  ntation
possibly model experience and there
big advantage fascinates her and which
facilitates things with mathematica is that
from a certain number of data points
we will be able to reconstruct in fact quite
easily a continuous model
from only a few points since the
mathematical to it has this facility of being
able to manufacture functions
so we can simply make the
problem which was initially a problem
we only had a few points your bubble
is in a way we can
finally make this problem continuous by
using this aspect  of mathematics and
this third notebook was to show
that we were able to develop
an experiment, that is to say find more
or less the main parameters to
respect the main lines that it
was absolutely necessary to respect to
carry out an experiment with a notebook
of the charges gives is therefore this aspect there
it is a
the device that we carried out
following this study of which  we used
mathematics in part to carry out this
study it is the realization of a
calorimeter which makes it possible to measure the
dielectric losses in the components
of the electronics of power and thus
the calorimetry device which we made
serves precisely to measure the  amount of
heat emitted by
power electronics components which is
not necessarily possible today with
techniques other than
metric calorie techniques
so we used mathematics a
essentially for that, i.e.
dimensioned this  device but also
finding the properties the right
properties and therefore the right materials
behind which will allow us to
make this device
one of the advantages of mathematics
now is the manipulated function
is which allows us to see in direct
time it is still enough  great
indeed to see the influence of
parameters in an extremely fast
and very visual way